for us this sound holds immense
emotional value this sound symbolizes
life love and Slovakia
slovakia has traditionally seen itself
as the heart of europe for the next six
months its pulse will become the pulse
of the entire european union we have
many ideas and even more ambitions and
yet we're not only concerned with how
our presidency will help slovakia we're
asking plain and simple
what will our presidency bring to the
european union this is our answer we
will work hard systematically and
persistently on issues that are
important to all EU member states and
their citizens we have a clear plan for
tackling priority issues we are
determined to help Europe avoid
fragmentation and enhance resilience we
will pay particular attention to making
a migration and asylum policies
sustainable
we want Europe to be prepared for
investments and new jobs this is why we
will focus on creating the right
environment that allows European
projects to get off the ground
how by mobilizing investment tools by
deepening the economic and monetary
union by helping small and medium sized
enterprises within the capital markets
Union and by strengthening the banking
union
since we understand what connected
Europe means we will devote our efforts
to common European projects
such as the single market the energy
union and the digital single market
we will therefore focus on challenges
that require a common approach and
common European solutions
such challenges include the previously
mentioned sustainable migration policy
as well as the European neighbourhood
policy and EU enlargement
these are the issues we're acting as an
honest broker we will seek solutions
benefiting the entire Union as
presidency we will be chairing one of
the three main EU institutions the
Council of the European Union which
represents the EU is 28 member states
the meetings at different levels from
technical to ministerial
we'll take place in Brussels Luxembourg
and Bratislava
and in doing so we will show you
Slovakia her beauties charms and secrets
Slovakia the country holding the
presidency of the Council of the
European Union from the 1st of July to
the 31st of December
Slovakia recharging Europe